Візовий режим принципі треба було у вас
ти з москвою і в росію ну а так не знаю
просто вже все втомився з'явитися та хворі
чини війни вони знають рів глибше паркан
вище я затягну непотрібну за росію
ніби x менше би країни ми на рівні
interest is [ __ ] поняття питання
нарізати я думаю що його вже давно трава
води тец і режим шату як столиця до
громадян України йти споживають на
територію Російської Федерації за раз
незаконно ростуть і нами погляд але я
думаю що не потрібна це ліза тому що
вільне пересування тону складності
буде створювати тому я думаю що
необхідно залишитися на тому ж рівні як і
раніше у вільне переміщення від таких
братів треба подалі бути чесно мені
все одно